well Euclid had the the straightedge and
the compass that those were the tools
that he had available he didn't have a
very good paper a completely different
approach that you can take to
constructions which is well it's much
less classical and so it's less talked
about is is to use folding paper instead
of a straight edge and a compass now if
you think about it
folding paper uses nothing first of all
you can't ever do circles you'll never
be able to fold a circle onto a paper so
all you have ever straight lines if you
think about is this stronger or weaker
than this set of tools that your kid was
using the intuitive answer is that it
must be weaker but sometimes the
intuitive answer is not the right answer
let me just jump right in and show you
how to trisect an angle by folding paper
what I'd like you to realize is that
essentially you have a straight edge
because if you have two points that you
previously constructed somehow then you
can fold the paper so that those two
points are on the crease this is exactly
the same thing as connecting them by a
straight edge even better you can do
perpendicular bisector in a single step
because you can fold the paper so that
these two points cover each other and
when you do that the created crease will
be perpendicular to the line segment
connecting those points and it will cut
it exactly in half because they covered
it up so to trisect an angle first you
have to create an angle a right angle is
not very interesting you can trisect the
right angle with straightedge and
compass which is probably an important
point to make it's not that there's no
angle whatsoever that you can trisect
it's that you can try second arbitrary
angle so 90 degrees you can try sex
because you can construct a 30 degree in
so we want to create an arbitrary angle
so that our job is not so easy
so I'll just fold the paper so that the
bottom of this crease is right at the
corner so
this is the angle we created it
arbitrarily we don't know how big it is
so I'll try to draw a line just inside
the crease okay you're going to try a
set to that I'm going to try that so
first we fold the paper in half so I
just fold the bottom up to the top so
that they match exactly then I fold the
bottom up to the half so now I have this
crease at the halfway so now I have
these two creases one up here and one
down here now here's the trick I'll mark
two points one is this bottom of the
angle yep the tip and the second one is
this point on the edge of the paper
that's halfway up I will fold the paper
so that this point at the tip of the
angle lines up matches this line this
crease that I created before and this
point halfway up the paper matches this
line which is the angle itself so I'm
going to fold it and fiddle it around
okay now once I found that alignment I'm
going to put my hand down and crease the
line and then I take a pen and mark this
point where the tip got okay open it up
and another important point to mark is
very this crease that that I just
created with this last fold where that
intersects the bottom line so you might
already see where this is going
yes I will fold to connect the tip of
the angle with this marks point and then
fold again to connect the tip of the
angle with the other mark
magic
let's do dessert angle that's it so
since we are folding we can check that
not prove it but check it by folding the
crease and see that it matches up and
then folding this crease in and see that
it matches up so the three so if you
want to prove that that it's an exercise
it's doable if you remember your
congruent triangles what power does
origami have that the straight edge
encompassed didn't have exactly a very
good question
so the the trick was this one step that
I did which was taking these two points
and lining them up with two lines so if
you if you allow that step which is a
reasonable step i mean if ever if I have
a paper it's it's very easy to do so the
key is that if you translate this step
to what it does to coordinates the same
way that I told you about in the context
of straightedge and compass what it does
is this crease that it creates is a
shared tangent of two parabolas and to
solve that equation to find a shared
tangent of two parabolas you need to do
something cubic that said that was the
one thing that would be on Euclid that
was the one thing that's that's be on
Euclid and and it turns out that with
origami phrased in terms of what are the
constructible numbers what are all the
coordinates that we can construct we can
do addition subtraction multiplication
fractions square roots
and cube roots so origami is more
powerful than Euclidean geometry it's
more powerful than your clearly and
geometry even better your if I give you
any cubic equation you can construct by
origami the solution so you could solve
a cubic equation which is the formula is
is really really big and ugly and hard
to plug into you can solve it just by a
simple folding mechanism and then
measuring the solution so I for example
I showed you how to do square root 2 I
showed you how to do 3 I show you how to
do 1/3 it turns out that you can do all
numbers that just involve fractions and
square roots and addition and
subtraction but there's a problem with
cube roots so what this guy proved it is
that you will never be able to do cube
roots